you
hi everyone is cherrymon chess calm and
paired up playing now a 3-2 game against
an opponent a familiar opponent same
guys last time so at least I have a
different color let's try the caro-kann
woo what is white cooking up with that
move D v e5 I guess I'm going to react
with the e5 change of plans
I'm expecting d4 and I'll go with d6 oh
okay
hmm I wonder if I could strike in the
center and play this for a gambit let's
try it this is a little bit awkward for
the night on e - okay
the computers going to be very helpful
for this game I have a feeling very uh
aggressive start to this one a lot of
pawn tension I'm not sure what to make
of it I don't want to allow pawn takes
here don't really have much choice
let's take like this C Knight takes know
so playing it as a gambit trying to grab
some space here well let's try and hang
on to this guy whoa talk about super
sharp there's certainly a super-sharp
game here so okay a lot of pawn moves um
that's all I've done so far I think it's
important to hang on to c5 reinforce d4
I'd like to challenge this pond the
night isn't on f3 to reinforce that
point okay huh okay this is wild pawn
takes I'm helping them to develop d4 94
Bishop b7 hmm
all right I know I'm helping them to
develop but let's see how they work
around this right here and I need a lot
of development in soon very soon there's
a Bishop b5 checks Queen a4 checks and I
should probably pull the trigger on a
move very quick in such a sharp position
here time will be super important hmm
how to complete development not easy
Knight here let's try it it could be
pinned but I'll throw a quick question
to the bishop on pawn takes nope not
going for that trying to get play Knight
g5 is this too much grabbing another
pawn probably hmm not sure how to
complete development midnight h6 huh
okay
so much for playing fast huh I'm going
to shot I'm going to try for maybe
queenside castle my queen and kenya are
on the same diagonal scary I realize
this might be an idea to break open the
position that might be happening right
away Knight g5 Knight h6 pawn push will
see their king is still in castled one
move away and this is not a happy home
going Queen side but I'll run with it
the Castle queenside castling Knight g5
Knight h 6 e 6 that's tough maybe I
should be inserting one more developing
move here
mm let's try let's you know let's try
this I think on Knight h5 I'm just going
to queenside castle hmm or maybe I could
get away with pushing I do have this
square covered a couple times what a
super-sharp position my night could be
kicked at any moment now with b5 on B
takes probably bishop takes I don't know
that I want to well if they really want
to eliminate my beep on they're going
they're going to be able to do that
ok castling kingside is also a little
bit scared because this is where they
have some space moves like f5 e 6f 6 I
do have pressure on e5 though maybe I
should look into the positives that I
have so I may be restricting a move like
this they take spawn so they're certain
they're really calculating something
good here I'm expecting ok mmm
let's take with the pun reinforce this
guy maybe maybe I have to go in this
direction Knight h6 I think I have to I
have to defend f7 this move is happening
but I have this move do I not I'm
hitting the bishop in defending f7 I can
no longer rely upon this guy I do have
this move doing that am I missing
hmm okay
I feel like ooh that move huh
okay yeah let's go back here I still
have this secure barely pawn takes pawn
takes here and I could kingside castle
but while these squares here if I took
I'm dropping my night on h6 right here
I'm not sure what to do maybe I could
grab this guy uh I think I want a
queenside castle soon okay
Knight here I guess is going to happen
queenside castle Bishop check let me
throw in a punch here okay I got a punch
thrown in let's play here dropping this
pawn yikes
ooh there's also that move isn't there
okay running for the hills here hmm okay
I'm not sure what to even even comment
on got to cover these light squares not
easy this Queen could kill me at any
moment maybe rook to e8 I guess a passed
pawn I want to just trade a little bit
back rank possibilities to keep my eyes
open for them maybe rook to c8 or Queen
to b6 no I don't want to give this
square up I guess here for starters
maybe rook c7 now queen bee eh I guess
here Knight check and I have that
covered rook check King here rook check
coming in got a run for the hills oh
there goes my queen
now that's more than that I'll be
getting mated here
queen is lost or just looking for a mate
I just dream of that got to recapture
maybe my my king could help out I do
have two connected passed pawns so we'll
see
is there a mate here can I save my rook
okay I got to go here
block with a queen check I'm attacking
the knight let's just get my rook defend
or maybe even behind this pawn I'm
missing any mates I guess here tough to
comment and check run over here I have
the square covered right here okay okay
the bishops picked up I guess right here
can't take twice on this square because
the back ranks tough maybe you can wink
a block I guess get pushing with this
guy okay I got advanced this pawn that's
my only hope and it's not much okay no
skewers might be a little it might be a
little bit tricky
we'll see try and keep them under time
pressure let's go here want to keep
pushing this pawn less than 10 this is a
bit tricky for them hmm okay they might
have to go for a perpetual yeah I think
this is a draw we're going to see maybe
their checks I've run out okay I have to
keep threatening to get a queen they're
banking a lot of time once again flying
off the increment increment quite quite
a bit again I did this in the last game
okay um actually I've banked some time
in there allowing this hmm
well I got I got a go for it so let's
see if I could hunt down these ponds
actually this is a win or is it let's
approach here let me see hang on let's
approach with the king hmm hang on
yeah let's go with the king again this
was not a useful check at all not at all
yeah that was that was a terrible
terrible move ah they're marching hmm
okay maybe one little trick if they
Queen if they Queen right now mmm there
was something right at the end I'm
pretty sure that's that's efficient and
yeah I got nothing here King here and
then pawn push they have another pawn to
even be working with pawn push will do
it as well ah let's resign that one mmm
I thought I had something at the end I
wonder what the story is with that rook
rook versus two pawns that one thing I
can say is that that check what a sharp
game that turned out to be right from
right out of the game this check right
here was not useful right at what point
right here that did nothing and I was
thinking hmm I was thinking I could do
one of these like attacks from the side
and then as soon as the pawn moves I
could get behind but the King is right
there hmm we'll see what the computer
has to say on this ending I'll be very
curious about
this one but I made it far too easy like
if I'm coming here right now hon push
huh don't know I don't know we're going
to have a look at it there's going to be
a lot of suggestions by the computer I'm
sure a lot of ups and downs but I will
see where we can improve that was one of
the wackiest starts I've had in a while
to a chess game just a tremendous amount
of tension very difficult to find good
moves and I didn't get a king safety
that's for sure
lack of development in the early stage
but anyhow let me let me jump right in
you know we'll see what we could take
away from this wild start to a chess
game okay let us see where we can
improve here crazy start a problem with
the e5 and there's d6 and I think it
said d5 quickly I mean it should be fine
right opening just challenging the
center I tried to I tried to open it up
a little bit I was open to like moves
like this this is what I had in mind
stuff like this trying to make it a
little bit awkward for them to complete
kingside development in well with this
move here after takes e4 I'm no longer
playing against a white pawn on e5 and
so it's so much more smooth of course to
deploy that King Knight to his favorite
square get the bishop out get castled if
they're going to grab another pond then
it's completely you know it's a
completely different story from what
happened in the game which was well it's
switched in the game my opponent had a
lead in development I was up material
and now it's the other way around okay
well that's what that was my intention
anyhow to play it as a gambit on pawn
takes to not capture but instead just
push here
okay well they reacted very
energetically with d4 I played eat XD
it's fine with that
c5 okay I guess we could kind of expect
the computer to suggest these moves
though ones that are hanging onto some
material okay right here is where it's
already suggesting development hmm with
knight c6 Knight h6 also popped up
mm-hmm I'm probably going to too far
astray with the b6 huh to weakening I
mean it's still holding an advantage but
you know what in positions like these
it's one where you have to give it some
time to think
extra sharp positions let's just run
with this developing move I would have
been fine if the knight was kicked on
takes what am i doing takes just
recapture and defend d4 that's so silly
mmm I think I was a bit fixated on this
idea of maintaining my pawn on c5
clearly with b6 I got away from the
basics playing bass playing knight c6
getting some pieces out hmm okay
wasn't uh rocket signs they're nice c6
okay the computer just puts things into
perspective doesn't it knight c6 again
but yeah maybe I'm going too much in the
pawn grabbing direction
still holding advantage but yeah I'm
kind of inviting my opponent to do what
improve their pieces you know I'm not
developing yet again this is eight moves
in this is a nice uh well eight pawns a
pawn moves in a row not good
something's clearly gone wrong okay
finally have a piece out but now it's
already tipping in White's favor and I
imagine
me yeah on and a half advantage and I
think it's just way downhill they're
calling out for Knight f5 right away oh
my goodness
look out 96 that it would have crushed
me Queen c7 92 d6 I don't even want to
look any further it's just awful can't
work around the knight on d6 kidding me
well I'm lucky to have even gotten 10
moves into the game that would have been
a killer and I'm sure there's a just
deadly moves one right after the other
around here Knight g5 it already likes
Knight h 6 e 6 i was pointing this out
especially if I was a Castle queenside
in a bishop recapture I'm in a pin Queen
e7 Castle queenside castle wow what a
wild position okay should be e 7b takes
this is just busted lost a very small
window of opportunity here I had to
focus on development and I clearly was
not doing that hmm I'm not usually like
that either when it comes to a material
but I really liked having my d4 pawn oh
I just I wanted to maintain support of
that pond with a pond okay well I
imagine it's lost from this point on
let's see where there are some shifts it
doesn't like f5 it shoots for East six
right away just blasting open the
position so plenty of other ways my
opponent could have approached this one
but hmm with n f5 yeah this is just very
very ugly f5 gives me some hope I guess
Knight a5 didn't even come to mind as it
has even now they should be 5 I guess
we're going for a queen exchange Wow
sort of been like a best-case scenario
okay I grabbed upon and it's losing with
f6 and also this move still and move
they played I guess the big question is
the only big question is was it a draw
at the end because here it's just
completely winning in so many ways maybe
even missed mates for white as you're
seeing + 2 + 3 + 5 + 6 where was the
killer shot right around here when it's
reading + 8 you know there's a problem
there you go mate + 9 making 8 7 million
for so they did miss the mate kingi 5
and they had a mate in 3 they played
takes they're still winning but what's
they made exactly this is where they had
some a little bit of a think rookie 6
Queen takes Queen takes here mate and I
guess the other one was on this move
King here rookie 7 within Queen here
next hmm ok still winning when I ate a
second okay kingi 7 it's read zero
because it's thinking it's a repetition
no draw but no this is obviously a win
for white so let's just get to that
ending I'll be curious about if I could
have held that to a draw my opponent did
have a perpetual and I think that ever
was off the table I could have gone for
that at any moment and yep yeah so right
okay I guess it is going to be hold a
bowl it's reading as zeros now okay in
okay so I could only manage a draw so
this is drawable let's see what the
accurate move is rook da one wrong slip
and it's going to be lost okay King
there is apparently fine h6 rook d7 hmm
okay I didn't play rook d7 King here
this is still holding I had to find an
accurate move here and my next one was
not it mm-hmm
okay yeah the check did not help at all
so I guess it's pretty much locked in
that I have to play rook to d8 yeah I
mean I'd have to do that right away I
mean why I don't know I don't know rook
to rook here is just helping the king
and only then I'm returning here so d8
let's see what the draw is exactly g5
King f3 hmm approaching this pawn is no
good no it's still good I'd probably go
with this but uh let's see let's see
this King f3 move what's the idea with
that suppose they push now there's rook
d2 and if King here rook d1 King here
king f4 this is like one of those
endgame studies King here well that runs
into a mate in one you don't want to do
that and I'm king here King f3 king h2
rook D - ok it makes sense and it's
interesting that this pawn on g6 and
that one line there is getting is is
helpful to black because it does take
away up a safe Square from the White
King moving in this direction here so
that's interesting my other question is
suppose on this instead of King f3 with
that idea king f4
does it have the same thing in mind
after g6 yeah same thing in mind so this
is this is a very useful thing to take
away this is this is really the main
thing I mean the the opening for me you
know when I'm playing the blitz games
I'm trying I'm trying to take something
away from it for myself those of you
watching if you're benefiting from this
that's great as well but the biggest
thing I'm taking away is not as much the
opening thing in me not developing but
this endgame right here just seeing how
there's this missed opportunity not not
seeing these possibilities for
threatening checkmate or also ideas of
getting the rook behind here for a
skewer so on g7 what's the draw here
rook d2 I'm King d1 it's just this stuff
back and forth so the only other test is
King here and now we have rook d1 so
this combination of mate threat King h2
is needed I guess and here we have King
f4 very cool King h3 King here and if he
continues to walk in this direction we
continue to walk in this direction yeah
this is one of those this is this is end
games study like problems that's that's
really interesting for it to pop up in a
this game here that I just played but
what a wild start and a very interesting
ending something I certainly took away
from this is this ending here how I
could have done better and how I could
have of course not helped out the white
king prior to playing to d8 but a very
interesting way to go ahead and hold
that position and anyhow as usual feel
free to leave any comments in the
comment section below to this video and
I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you